hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space alright I just
went up the stairs that's why it's a
little different but I just had it the
same anyway text law united we you said
you've been looking on march to the past
20 years might have missed the fastest
growing religious mood in history oh
that's this religious thing the church
that everyone's talking about I'm
guessing 78 billion dollars of stock
that's a rich Church let's give another
basics Michael Altman the precious aroma
apology biggest cover-up ever instituted
by her government the marker oh they
found the marker here key to eternal
life
rebirth and ascension to heaven the
kicker's you have to die for us that's
how it mostly is but uh taking all your
money as bad oh these ranks are achieved
by giving money and power to the church
that makes sense
Church also requires members to donate
their bodies after death okay
that's weird mausoleum ships whoo hi
that's some heavy stuff but not my
concern
deputies in my way up poach me the
plague okay what am i doing I don't have
enough nodes usually I have a lot of
nodes but right now kind of short on
nodes that way but
hallelu red carpet so lush but no no no
no the shuttle is mine I control access
to the shuttle okay if we could make the
journey ah could fix everything
I'm sorry mr. Clarke
unless you can prove to me you can get
it spaceworthy again I'm afraid I can't
let you through I need to know you're on
my side okay that's weird it said he was
a playback an audio log who's talking to
the person so odd okay going this way
hook spits this yep
Amer ammo all right
Oh who's that oh you want almost and so
I don't hold this one oh yeah
doesn't cross with champagne ah now she
aways for transforming a rebirth huh are
you Ron a thread a Juris sense mr.
temple that's the engineer that there
was talking about before what do you
know you will pay your punch
come on witness a conviction of a true
believer a your true belief just lie on
computer for something what the hell
y'all ready my framerate just dropped
did you stab him in the head my friend
right what the hell after you buddy for
making my framerate go to crap yeah
there we go okay I don't know what that
was all about something in that scripted
sequence didn't agree with my computer
or perhaps I don't know but it's all
better now
what are we waiting for well hello you
I'm gonna get you oh yes sorry guys that
sucks those are like the only two
survivors who are actually doing
something on the ship they were like I
think it's like an analogy then for
Isaac and his girlfriend Nicole Nicole
yeah let's go see what's up with the
body probably gonna turn into monsters
pretty quickly oh I hate this goop it's
everywhere slowing me down now cool bro
cool don't know what suddenly makes it
hard I could understand it was like a
foot of mud up hey back off buddy
back off mm head slit yeah
okay goodbye I'm surprised you don't
that thing doesn't blow up hanging off
your arm when you're walking around okay
those guys are I don't want you turning
into zombies sorry buddy hi lady
sorry safety first I get off my leg
she's crawling on my leg
she was a monster yep y'all saw it
self-defense I go down here okay another
slow down slow down buddy oh yeah
ah what the hell
yo ed no no aah
what close that another one come on and
what the hell those things have been
getting me giving me less than
obsessively like they used to give me
one gave me a Ruby semiconductor but now
those didn't even give me crap with some
ammolite thing
all right whatever whatever okay Wow
whoa what do what do you just do oh holy
crap that's that's messed up bro take
some hey buddy what was that what did I
get huh
I don't even know something I came here
for oh uh I guess that's everything
getting out of here please
Oh was that a box yep all right
up we go okay um oh this again slowing
me down
mr. clock hello I really must speak with
you I'm very close to your position and
and I know you want to hear what I have
to say can explain all this so what
happened when you have the nerve cards
I'll let you into the security station
we must talk hey add NAB cards
the more than one cuz I've gotten one I
think that's what I got before yeah okay
yeah I'll come find you the circle I'm
gonna let me in before I don't see why
you let me in now whatever though whoa
Oh
hi I'm trying to deal with some here
don't slow down slow down command
I got a this cut by slice what you're
dead there we go oh that one was
prolific there we go okay goodness gravy
does not I wish they would just give me
the fire sticks again because I could
just widen shot him
oh no not a bathroom you only got to go
through the bath
what's with this shift in bathrooms I'm
making up for the Star Trek for the
Starship Enterprise
USS Enterprise we're all the bathrooms
on that ship
once again I hear flies why are there
flies on this ship
with all the air filters and whatnot
that would be but probably people either
querida manners I can't get to that Oh
key card to that I wish I was thinking
just fly by it
because not spamming
what else fun I'm trained is family is
like when I'm going up to a useable
panel point they're about to do the
plasma cutter for a little bit see how
it does the life support system and
police off B has been shut down you'll
have to find an override nearby to get
to the door all right I keep getting
these sporadic framerate drops I know
why it's been happening more and more
with my computers like when I first
started playing doing Let's Plays I
never got a single bit of lag or
framerate drop or anything but now all
of a sudden I'm getting sorts of stuff
wait it's at the elevator this is
something oh it's a crack another
bathroom oh you're not dead were you
were you actually dead huh oh we're
trying to defame the tricking me Linux
bet it was dead but it wasn't really
dead because it was actually dead
whereas I thought it was really alive
okay anyway
what have you mentioned that there's an
achievement for going through the whole
game with the plasma cutter I should
have made that my challenge to actually
try to get that achievement by the end
but I would imagine that would be hard
because like a some parts where you need
rapid-fire like those little squiggly
guys you don't have a virus to ground it
kind of swarm on oh this looks ha ha I
know like this part this part is good
for me she good
I'm gonna do it
get-get-get yeah there you go ah come on
oh come on
ah no framerate drop come on don't I
don't I don't
there we go Oh your ass bag if you
that's hard to do with that plasma
cutter so I imagine if you don't get
good shots or if you're on a higher
difficulty would be pretty cutting it
pretty close okay where am I Oh hold
down one do I need to use my special
telekinesis to do that override door
lock overridden what door lock where
door lock
oh no I trying to press a bunny huh I
mean this plasma cutter
I guess black cutter I guess it'd be
entirely possible to go through the
whole game cos I see you I got that one
nope not that one
what i'ma do what i'ma do
oh that door I'll see that door come on
hazardous condition please contact oh
hello
Big Bertha gone ain't nothing nothing
try it
okay um up you're not dead
haha knew it get over here are you doing
there we go okay
oxygen well this is gonna be easy if
they're just gonna give me up I really
don't see why there was a neat upgrade
to your oxygen because any time they put
you in a vag sick okay trying system now
free us as it is condition specialist
hey it's a baby doc don't know doggone
anything tentacles just because I know
uh your tentacles let me see him yeah we
see what you got was that head oh no not
today not today miss me
blowed gone gone yep there go easy peasy
alright need Austin
I come in here for a reason is they're
not chin doohickey in here I need to go
outside get more o inclined to mouth
some jicama oh where you come from
spell hold on slow down buddy no hello
no whoa
Wow plum ah get out here get I need
oxygen I need oxygen real bad real bad
where was it where was it where was it
there it is okay whoo all right okay
done go in there I can get the heck out
of here was that the only thing in here
can't have been no no way there had to
be more it's in here it's another
bathroom with all there's so many
bathrooms on this level I guess it is
the crew deck so good make sense lots of
people suppose I go when you gotta go
hazardous condition how to do something
else like a power node or something
whoa that's not looking too good okay
well I obviously can't go that way maybe
that was everything let me just
double-check kill the twitchy guy at
least wait this is a different way yeah
opted a senior it just is it is eerily
quiet there's nothing wrong with volume
but it's just because I'm in the back
everything's kind of muffled um
locks but no nothing else I would have
figured there would have been not you
again not you you know inside oh man
you're so quick quick oh ok need ox yeah
ok that was it I just wanted a big sir
so get out of here get out of here how
are you
wait this is something new this is
something something but I can't stay oh
there's the power note I'll come get in
a second ah get oxygen Oh - OH - oh all
right upgrading the oxygen would be like
a convenience sing you'd be able to go
and get all this done without wasting
your time ok now we are good life
support and final system malfunction
hazardous condition please contact Oh
wonder what makes them turn black I mean
some of them are normal colors will
normal as they can be being mutated
flesh and all but some are just weird
all right that's all the time I got for
this episode though thank you all for
watching and I will see you in the next